toujours dans l'actualité en france la
loi bioéthique doit être adopté en
principe aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale pourtant le texte a été
discutée depuis deux ans maintenant non
sans quelques accrochages dans la rue
comme dans les hémicycles
on va retrouver justement notre reporter
mona amoud et l'or
[Musique]
bonjour von ah vous êtes devant
l'assemblée nationale où cette loi
bioéthique va finalement être adopté
c'est un projet de loi qui a été
longtemps débattu
débattue il a était attendue et comme
vous l'avez dit il a suscité bien des
réactions au sein de la classe politique
le texte avait été rejeté par les
sénateurs le 24 juin un sénat qui est
dominé par la droite c'est donc
l'assemblée nationale qui finalement
aura le dernier mot et ce texte devrait
être définitivement voté vous l'avez dit
c'est un projet de loi qui a commencé à
l'automne 2010 9
le vote d'aujourd'hui c'est finalement
le résultat de longs a rythmé par des
critiques à droite on a notamment vu
également plusieurs manifestations
organisées par des associations contre
le projet de loi bioéthique de son côté
l assemblée nationale soutenu par la
majorité présidentielle les députés de
gauche ont toujours soutenu ce projet le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
avait promis que des couples de femmes
pourraient s'inscrire dans un parcours
pma dès la rentrée ce sera donc le cas a
priori quelles sont les mesures phares
de ce projet mona
eh bien là plusieurs parmi elles il ya
l'ouverture bien évidemment de la pma
aux couples de femmes et aux
célibataires qui sera finalement
remboursé par la sécurité sociale ça
avait été discuté un moment donné ou
encore l'autorisation de l'auto
conservation des ovocytes alors
concernant l'accès aux origines une
disposition a été ajoutée qui permet aux
enfants nés de la pma d'avoir accès aux
informations des concernant les donneurs
et c'est d'honneur devront donc accepter
que leur identité soit connu
contrairement aux états unis où l'accès
aux données et partiellement et
partielle en tout cas si politiquement
est les discussions ont été très vives à
ce sujet est bien et il semblerait que
les français sont un peu plus ouverts à
ce sujet selon un sondage ifop 60 pour 7
67% des français sont favorables à la
pma pour toutes
merci beaucoup mona pour toutes ces
précisions mona amoud et l'or en direct
de l'assemblée nationale à paris ce
matin